thank you and good morning and welcome
to this latest meeting of the covert 19
public engagement board for trafford um
thank you for your attendance i have
apologies this morning from george
devlin are there any further apologies
at all
i don't see any thank you very much are
there any declarations of interest in
today's any of today's agenda items
no thank you can we take the minutes of
the last meeting on the 26th of january
as read and as a true and accurate
record
thank you and so without any further ado
we'll go on to the current update uh for
trafford from helen collins helen uh
have we can i just ask before you start
we talked last time about the government
advice on living with covid19 have we
received that yet is there anything
obviously there's work going on but i'll
hand over to you anyway thank you for
the update
thank you now we're still awaiting
further guidance from the government on
living safely with covid but there's
been lots of discussions and lots of
planning going on um
at northwest and national level in terms
of the next steps we're just waiting for
confirmation around that at the moment
but locally we have done some forward
and planning so what we're doing um as a
local team is we've reviewed what we
need for next year so um from the first
of april through to the 31st of march
and looking at the team so the hub and
the outbreak hub will remain in place
for the next 12 months and we will still
have support and oversight for testing
ppe vaccination
and community engagement and comms as
well so we will have an offer in
trafford because what we recognize is
from the 31st of march covert isn't
going to go away and um it's about how
we adapt as a local system and a gm
system to support our residents to live
safely with covid and to continue the um
real focus on improving vaccination
rates as well i think that's absolutely
crucial for us at the moment so that's
that's where we are locally at the next
pep board we will hopefully be able to
bring along um
our plan for the next 12 months so
what we're recognizing at the the moment
is that um similar to cold and flus uh
covert is likely to be a seasonal
illness so
i'm sorry to say this but i think from
next winter is likely to be another
challenging winter for us but at least
we've got the next um
six nine months to really think ahead in
terms of how we pull the system together
and and add the additional pressures
that covered will bring into our
planning so that's what we're doing in
terms of um
an rcg so our gold
trafford gold system is looking that
forward look to ensure that we are ready
for for anything else that comes along
um obviously
if things continue as they are through
the summer summer and spring and then
then we're looking in a reasonably
stable position but it's when we start
seeing the increases in autumn and
winter when people are having to to go
inside more when booster vaccination
wanes a little bit more so just thinking
very much about um
how we manage those situations so that
that's a priority for us at the moment
in terms of planning for the next 12
months
but in terms of an update for where we
are in trafford um although our rates
are still higher than we would like and
they are higher than we would like and
higher than we've seen um
early on in the pandemic
we are in a much much better position
than we were and it's you know it's it's
a real relief to see the rates
continuing to to decline they're not
declining at the speed that we would
hope and it's unlikely that they are
going to fall away at any particular
pace
but we are likely to um
have we lost her have we have we lost uh
helen
that message if you click the wrong
thing disconnects you immediately ah
right let's hope she can cut back in
alex can you
invite her back in
i will i'll try my best to get her back
now
she's just said that she's on her way
back in
great thank you
okay she's just turning now
welcome back helen
you're on mute so you take something
with you and carry on
it all started so well i'm sure zoom
absolutely hates me for some reason i
don't know what i've done to do too many
quizzes on the saturday night through
lockdown i think maybe i don't know
but yeah so we're looking in a better
position so where we are up to friday
the 4th of february is
582.1 per 100 000
and so in terms of numbers that's
1383 cases in our residence up to the
friday the 4th of february
the week before that
um we were at 813 per hundred thousand
so you can see that we've declined 300
per 100 000 there which is really good
um i need to talk to you about a little
bit of a change in the the figures in a
moment um but i'll go through the key
headlines first
so our rates for our over 60s although
they are continuing to decline they're
not declining at the rate that we would
have hoped either so we're seeing a rate
of 335 per hundred thousand
uh in our over 60s and that's compared
to the week before which is three six
eight so you can see we've not seen that
drop in that age group
and i've um we've asked bienae to join
us today i'm just going to speak after
kirsty's spoken about outbreaks just to
talk through all the work that's gone on
for that population the over 60s
population particularly in our care
homes and our supported accommodations
so in terms of positivity our positivity
rate has dropped as well so we were in
the high 20s i think last time we met
this time our positivity rate is 13
which means that of everybody who's
testing in the community 13 of them are
testing positive so we still do have
high rates of um
infection circulating but not like we'd
seen previously
trafford is third highest in greater
manchester but the the difference
between the highest and the lowest
boroughs now isn't as extreme as it was
so the highest
borough at the moment is stockport on
700 and the lowest is oldham on 400 so
you can see there's not a huge
difference really there
our age groups as well we're all
decreasing they're all going down which
is really positive to see but again not
at the speed that we would have hoped
but they are going in the right
direction particularly in our school age
population and our um
that the group that we assume have been
affected by the school age population
the parent parents group as well of 30
to 44s but kirsty can talk us through
the activity that we've seen
particularly in our primary schools
the geographies have been really
interesting and again it's often an
impact of that reduction and that's the
the lower rates across the different
wards but broadhead
is our highest at the moment followed by
hale central village and ashton on
mersey
we've had a real focus recently on
buckley saint-martins which is
partington because we hadn't really seen
partington
um at the top of our wards throughout
the pandemic but we have i would say
over the last three four months seen
partington consistently within the top
five so our community engagement team
are doing some really focused work with
the population and uh hoping to link him
with counsellor colleagues out in
partington as well to to work in terms
of understanding what's happening in
portington and how we can support
partington community
around covert as well
um in terms of hospital admissions we
we're pleased to say that the hospital
missions have decreased as well so um
this is for across the whole of greater
manchester not just trafford um going
into greater manchester hospital so
there were
270 admissions the week ending june 30th
of january
um and that was a decrease from three to
three for the previous comparable time
frame as well so you can see you know
it's a decrease of 50 admissions there
but what we have heard from our
colleagues in adult social care and the
nhs is the pressures are still
significant for our services and our
systems so we must be mindful that um
the impact that covert has had on our
our system has been significant
and then our numbers of our residents in
occupied ventilation beds has dropped as
well so we have a lower number now 104
compared to three five one three five
for the previous time period which is
which is good to see and it's a
testament to
the uh ventilation the ventilation the
vaccine program
and finally our deaths you know as
unfortunate that any death from covert
is have remained low and i think what
we're seeing now is that tale so if you
remember we talked about we often see a
delay and a tale um in terms of
hospitalizations and deaths coming from
the peaks i think we're starting to see
the end of that now hopefully and and we
hope that our death rates will continue
to decrease
so change in terms of the data
um it's been really interesting to see
but a little bit hard to process at
times is that now they are reporting and
we're getting reports on reinfection
rates so this is people
who have coveted who or who report a
second positive for covid 90 days from
their first positive
um
and so we're now seeing that data and
tom and gerard our analysts and daniel
have done some brilliant work and we can
see where those reinfections are highest
and where we are seeing the higher
reinfection rates are very much in the
north of our borough which i don't think
is a surprise to any of us in terms of
why that is happening it you know it
could be around the time we saw the
north of the borough was very much um in
the first couple of waves where activity
was the highest so there's that kind of
the acquired immunity may have dropped
we know that our vaccination
uptake is lower and we also know that um
we have multi-generational households in
that those communities in the north
barbara but also um factors around
housing and uh occupation as well so in
terms of the living wave wage kind of
jobs and the um less likely to be
working from home more likely to be in
the workplace so we're very much seeing
the reinfection rates in the north um
and also interestingly in this in the
west of the borough so erbsten and
flixton area
and so we're looking at this as um
as an analyst team really because we're
really interested in why we've seen
the high rates in the west
and the high reinfection rates in the
west
but when we compare it to um
neighborhoods such as sale for example
they're both they both have similar
demographics earnest and sale in terms
of you know family community school age
communities but we're just trying to
understand
what has made them so different in terms
of the rates so tom our analyst is
looking at that at the moment whether
there is an answer to that question i'm
not sure but it's worth asking that
question i think very much
so that's reinfection data and the
reinfection data as well it is really
interesting to see that there is an
element of um it's a bit arbitrary in
terms of the 90 days so i think in wales
for example the reinfection rates are
reported after 42 days so we will see a
difference in in between our kind of
devolved
um
nations as well so that's something
we're just watching at the moment and
looking to interpret
so i've talked to you about um the plan
for the next 12 months
um and i'll hand over to my colleagues
for the other updates but um
happy to see any questions that anyone
may have thank you
thank you helen uh that's really really
uh helpful that update
particularly the fact that we seem to
now be planning ahead to have an
offering traffic for the next 12 months
at least
are there any questions at all got to
council accordingly first followed by
councillor blackburn
um thanks chair um i'm just wondering if
we've got any i'm interested in the data
because data
data reliability probably is changing it
it may be more accurate it may be less
accurate um i noticed the um we we're
departing quite considerably from the um
the zoe app um
so a lot of people are not
it seems to me that a lot of people are
living with it and also not reporting it
to a certain extent i've heard
anecdotally of lots of people that think
they had cl cold and haven't bothered
testing so have we got data on the
amount of lateral flow tests that are
being
distributed
that from chemists and things like that
because it'd be useful to know whether
they're still being called upon if we
see if we saw a massive drop in lateral
flow tests being
if you like collected from the resources
that would that would throw further down
onto the dates of position
the data on positive testing i think
because it showed that a lot of people
are not testing um
so i'm just i'm i'm really trying to get
behind the data because it it
attitudes have definitely changed now
we're in a new
um we're in a new part of the um
pandemic
to a certain extent some people are
living more with it than others and i
think some people are almost ignoring it
so any data like that that sort of gives
us a
background to it would be useful
thanks council accordingly so i'll hand
over to ben um in a moment but i just
wanted to
to say um
i think that's why one of our key
messages is about if you're testing
irrelevant of whether it's negative then
you must please register your test so we
can see who is testing and who's not
testing
and then the other thing is the data
is getting
um
more difficult to interpret i would say
because of the the some of the issues
that are being um identified and that
you talked about so this is kind of when
we're thinking about that forward plan
into the next 12 months is thinking
about our vulnerable
and the communities that we need to
really focus on and work with and
protect from covered rather than trying
to interpret
the information robustly at a population
level so we are really mindful of of the
fact that the data is changing very much
but again our analyst tom he does
provide a really good table of um of
those positives that are reported what
proportion of them are reported via lfd
and via pcr so that's available as well
and what we have seen is
um
at one point obviously it was all pcrs
and then we've seen the steady kind of
increase in lfds and i would say at the
moment about 80 of the positives that
are reported reported through lfd rather
than pcr
so there is still activity in the
community but i'll hand over to ben in
terms of numbers of tests thanks ben
thanks helen so i mean just on a
kind of basic level um just in our
community collect sites so that's the
five traffic libraries that we have plus
three community hubs we gave out
436 boxes of tests we commenced on the
24th for jan um and 304 tests week
commencing the 31st that's a 30 drop in
that time period so in terms of your
question counselor yes we are seeing a
drop and that has continued um following
on throughout january i think a large
part of that is obviously so much
emphasis was was uncovered over that
christmas period and obviously everyone
was you know seen very vulnerable
relatives um and i think moving past
that period maybe people not going out
as much um at least not having quite as
many family occasions means that we're
not seeing that same level um of of take
above low test um and i would expect
that trend to continue i think over the
coming weeks
um
i think it'd be useful to keep getting
that data and see how it changes i think
it's probably going to tell us a story
that um that that the week on week
changes in
lateral flow maybe one week isn't enough
to really interrogate it but
it'd be useful over a month or two to
see how that changes and then we can see
because a lot of people did walk by as
soon as
they could at christmas so
that contaminates the data a little bit
it absolutely does but no i'm that's
perfectly fine for me to continue to
report about our data um at pebb going
forward
uh thanks ben uh councillor blackburn
you have a question
yes thank you can i ask is there any
indication that
that holidaymakers who have been holiday
abroad and returning back home have come
back with covid
uh we don't have any um fixed data on
that uh councillor blackburn i mean the
assumption would be that
there may be a proportion that will
return you know it's one of those things
but we don't have
clear information on that at the moment
um
i can look to see we can have a look
through our data sources to see if
there's travel related but because of
the the pcr rules now and policies
around travel
and it's less clear in terms of
returning
um
holiday makers ben i don't know if
you've got a view on that in terms of um
testing and travel or any horizon
scanning that you might be aware of um
i just wondered because um if you go
abroad you've got to book a pcr test
you know a couple of days after your
return and i'm just wondering how many
don't actually do the test
so we we don't um all this we've not
seen scene data on that so um i can't
comment now but i can go away and see if
i can find anything further than that
council blackburn and come back to and
let you know
thank you uh council blackburn kelson
new cross you've got a question
thank you um i'm sorry i got i lost
connection just there um so if this has
already been asked please tell me um so
going back to you were mentioning um you
uh doing different areas
had different levels and i'm just
because i'm represent village it always
comes you know always i always hear it
um but my question is you're not doing
it actually on the ward level are you
there's much smaller level blocks of
data sets we're looking at because for
instance my ward is it's not 50 50 but
there's a large split between one side
and the other where
one side has multiple indices of
deprivation and the other does not and i
would have thought the
that would have give given a difference
in outcome um
of of uh of covid transmission so i'm
just wondering at what granularity
you're doing the data analysis thank you
thanks councillor new grosh so um we do
it at um um
msoa level so that's kind of a little
different towards
um and also um ward level so we get a
different kind of
levels but we often where we have areas
of concern or we want to see patterns
will then
go down to the local super output area
which is really small it's about 1500
people within the local super output
area and that will allow us to pick up
those sensitivities that you um describe
within village ward
so what we often do is that the data
that we report at top level we will
drill down if we have concerns so if you
um as a counsellor wanted to have a deep
dive or look at the particular area that
you're
concerned about we would be happy to
take that away we'd have to negotiate
time frames with you but would be happy
to to look at that for you um if that's
something that you'd be interested in
but i recognize that village ward is a
really interesting one isn't it because
it's quite different in terms of
um
the population that you serve
yes and thank you for the offer
thanks for uh cancer action have you you
want to ask a question
yeah it's about um admissions to
hospital really um
obviously you you do say that it is
slightly going down
which is uh
the good news and
um i just wonder how how they're
actually coping
uh you know in the hospitals uh with all
the pressures of they they're under uh
you did say also about
uh that there was uh 104
patients who were on ventilators
is that just in in trafford or is that a
cross greater greater manchester um and
i think the the the deaths as well that
you mentioned
you did you didn't say how how many
um
and
you know what what age groups
clearly it's probably the elderly who
who are dying but um it would be
interesting to know you know some of
those steps
thanks councillor acton so
um i'll leave the
how the nhs is coping to my colleague
mark um but if i answer the other two
questions first but in terms of um from
our perspective
with the nh with how our hospitals are
coping they are still under considerable
pressure we often see
the
um
the kind of discharge pressures in terms
of our care homes and and particularly
the the homes that our ipc and outbreak
team are supporting trying to you know
support the discharges into the
community
in terms of the ventilation beds that's
for the whole of greater manchester so
that's all residents from across greater
manchester who are admitted into a
greater manchester hospital and who are
then on supported ventilation within um
greater manchester so that's just the
data there
and in terms of the deaths um it's just
around sensitivities reporting small
numbers really obviously because these
are the trafford residents but we are
under 10 in terms of deaths what we are
doing at the moment is working really
closely with our colleagues at mft
to
do some
data analysis to understand
who is being admitted
in terms of age characteristics
um
if it is if it is that they are being
admitted with covid if they are emitted
with another condition but also have
covid
or um
or you know develop the infection whilst
in hospital
and so we're just looking at that piece
of work as you can imagine it's quite a
significant piece of work and the data
we are able to um
access is from april 20 20 so we'll be
able to see a really good um picture
across trafford with this data and it
will also allow us to understand health
inequalities as well that the pandemic
has has really identified
in terms of deaths as well we will be
looking at the death so
is it that
the individual died from covid or died
with covid so it's it's all kind of the
nuances within the data but we can we
will report back into um pebb when that
data is available but as you can imagine
it's quite a significant programme of
work i suppose because we are um
a public meeting it's just thinking
around the sensitivities of some of the
smaller numbers and the impact that this
may have on families if we report at
that level but we are thankfully
we do have small numbers of deaths as
tragic as they are but i'll just hand
over to mark now in terms of nhs
pressures thanks mark
can't hear you mark
am i off me now
my computer's
doesn't like zoom like helen um
so um
the hospitals are still
massively under pressure um but through
the omicron
um
wave it's been as much about staff
absences as it has been about the number
of cases
so
i've just been trying to find the data i
think in mft who take the majority of
trafford patients
they've currently got just under 300
patients
with covid
and that's not a massive number compared
to how they have been but they've got
just under 10 staff absences at the
moment
um and they did get up to 15
staff absences
um over christmas and new year which
compares to
you know pre-covered average staff
absences of three to four percent
so
the pressure on the hospital system
is is multifactorial there are a number
of patients
in there with covid that creates a load
of infection protection control measures
uh problems for the for the hospital
about how they operate so their their
ability to
behave and manage patients in the same
way they previously would have done is
affected by the infection and
they've got a far higher level of staph
absence
you know a lot of that's due to covered
than previously so
it is multifactorial it is slowly and
steadily improving as i said staff
absence has dropped significantly over
the last four or five weeks and is
continuing to improve
the
rates of general admissions and the
rates of people on intensive care
because i think in in mft
they're now at around 20 people um
requiring intensive care level of
support
um so they're all improving and
improving gradually and like helen i've
been in conversation with mft about that
breakdown of the people who are now
being admitted and the ones who are now
requiring you know the intensive care
and unfortunately the
the ones who are still dying um but we
haven't got
any data that we're in a position to
share with you at this point in time
i hope that answers the question yeah it
it it does um you know i think we all
realize the pressures that the nhs is
under this
this time and i do understand you know
with god to the death there's a lot of
sensitivity but i think some of the data
that um you know i've talked about i
think it is quite important to
understand
you know what it actually happened
thanks very much
thank you yeah we
completely agree with you we need that
data we need to learn the lessons and we
need to be in a position to
to do better or do as well as we can in
the future
thank you mark are there any further
questions for helen from anyone at all
i don't see any so we can move on then
and uh we'll move on to mass testing and
and ben welcome ben
thanks very much chair so
first of all um i just actually thought
after i finished speaking before council
blackburn um about testing um
actually in terms of travel
in terms of changes on i think it's 11th
feb um where fully passed any travelers
and under 18s don't need to take that
day to lecture flow test anymore after
they arrive so the data we're going to
get going forward anyway i think will be
very limited those aren't fully
vaccinated will still need to go and do
that day two and the pre-departure test
as well um but yeah going forward anyone
who is fully vaccinated won't need to
from the 11th
um otherwise then um to update so it's
another week another set of changes in
testing guidance in this instance it's
around adult care settings so that's
care home support living extra care etc
staff members will now be asked to take
electro flow test at the start of the
day each day that they're working
and due to this increased testing the
weekly asymptomatic pcr test is no
longer going to be required and although
that said pci testing will still be used
for symptomatic staff outbreaks and
anytime a person is a contact so the new
process ideally should lead to positive
cases being identified more quickly
rather than having to wait for those pci
results to return to the lab so that
hopefully should be really positive um
and they're asking for all adult social
care settings to implement that by the
16th of february
um otherwise um obviously i've already
referenced this a little bit before and
but demand for larger flow tests have
started to drop um which is positive in
terms of the fact that people now i find
it easier to get hold of waterflow tests
we're not having those same difficulties
that we saw before
um nonetheless team still done a huge
amount of work and handed out tests so
in the past eight weeks we've now given
out 120 000 individual tests which is
really really positive
and then finally key messages so as much
as electro flow tests are being used um
more please continue to get a pcr test
if you have any code with symptoms um
and otherwise before you go out and see
others definitely please take electro
flow tests well they're much easier to
get hold of and obviously in traffic you
can get them from stratford-um some sale
opticum and now partisan libraries so
there are a number of different options
for you when it comes to getting hold of
lots of flow tests and that's all for me
unless there's any questions
thank you ben are there any questions at
all for ben
i don't see any hands going up ben so
thank you very much indeed and we'll
move on then to um
contact tracing and outbreak management
welcome kirsty
good morning thank you
and
so the position across our comport a
significant increase um in our primary
schools in early years in terms of
outbreaks not so much in our secondary
schools so since the return after the
christmas break we had 38 primaries that
had an outbreak but that's now reduced
down to around about five that are
currently in an outbreak situation so
that's either within one class or maybe
across the school
so a much improved position across our
schools um this week and obviously many
of the schools are finishing for half
term on friday so hopefully we should we
shall see see that continue to decrease
um in that period schools have heavily
been hit with staffing contingency
issues just due to the sheer number of
corporate cases and activity in the
schools and the settings
and
as i said we've seen a massive
improvement in the case numbers across
the schools over the past two weeks or
so
and
although covert is present and although
there are a few outbreaks they are being
managed very well by the schools
and the highest case rate seemed to have
been
in the schools in uh saint mary's
timperley bolden and
and we have seen it across all year
groups but more so in cases more so in
years um two to six in the primaries
um
so that the older age groups in the
primaries and years seven eight and nine
in the secondary schools
um which
on the return to school in september i
think it was the opposite for the high
schools we were seeing it in the higher
year groups
and
i think we should just acknowledge that
schools are
still very much
managing covered situations but are also
back to business as usual for them in
terms of activities such as inspections
and exams and so that the pressures that
schools are facing we we do acknowledge
that
and and we from a public health team
we're just continuing to work with our
skills that are in an outbreak or want
advice and guidance and and we continue
to make recommendations that are in line
with the contingency framework so any
additional measures
and that we recommend we follow that
contingency contingency framework and
they're in place for the shortest amount
of time possible until that outbreak has
reached levels where where they can come
out of them additional measures
um i think it was probably reported at
the
the last
pair but from the thursday 20th of
january
need for face coverings in education
settings was removed
and
so we are supporting that approach from
a national perspective
but an education setting can decide to
recommend face coverings um if they see
case numbers increasing within the
setting
and
and we can recommend face coverings in
line with the contingency framework if a
class or school is in an outbreak
again keeping that in place for the
minimum amount of time but the the
blanket approach to face coverings is
that we've not kept them in place but
they can be advised if a school wishes
to due to the numbers are if they're in
an outbreak situation
and then very similar with
events across our schools we're keen
that events can go ahead across schools
ultimately the responsibility sits with
the
head and the governors
and as with sufficient mitigation most
events should be able to go ahead unless
they're experiencing high rates of
corvid or an outbreak in a class or year
group and even then there can be
contingency measures and measures put in
place and we continue to risk assess
them events and situations with schools
in terms of our workplace settings again
after christmas we saw a considerable
amount of activity across our business
settings
and that's improved incredibly and
currently we have no outbreaks in any of
our business settings which is really
really good news
um we've been doing some really close
work with the trafford center who've
done some fantastic work around
compliance checks and ensuring that the
the retailers are called safe so we're
also continuing with that piece of work
as well
um and then finally our level two
contact tracing so as we we always say
those are not reached by the national
team that come through to us locally we
have a team of contact races in place
and we've managed to reach over the past
couple of weeks 86 of our residents for
local contact racing
um from those that we've reached we've
completed contact tracing with 80 of
those so that's really good um
successful completion and it's put us at
the highest across gm in terms of our
contact racing rate so we just want to
thank you for to
our residents for engaging in that
contact tracing process
we continue to offer support to people
that are self-isolating
so this past week alone we've provided
support to 71 people
that are self-isolating which is
um
helpful because it means that they are
reaching out to us and they are
contacting us for that support
and if you remember back in june we did
the pathfinder on self-isolation support
where we did targeted postcodes
that external evaluation that's being
done all across gm
is currently being put together so we'll
we'll feed back on that at pebb once
it's ready um
as we understand it at present the
self-isolation support funds are due to
end on the 31st of march
so obviously we're gonna build that into
our plans of some of these things
ceasing and ending and what that might
look like
um echoing on some of ben's key messages
probably a little bit um touching on
some things if you test positive on an
lfd
there's no need to follow it up with a
pcr unless
um you have symptoms
or you want to claim that testing tray
support payment i know we've said before
but that's really important that they
follow that
up with a pcr test and that must be done
within the um self-isolation period
um and
just a key message around unvaccinated
closed contacts that aged over 18 years
in six months
must self-isolate and that is a legal
requirement so if you're a contact and
you're unvaccinated the case still
remains that you must still self-isolate
for 10 days and you can't um
early release from that with the day
five and six testing
i think that's it from me
uh thanks curtis that was a very very
full and thorough update thank you can i
just certainly support to schools
by the outbreak management team has been
outstanding i'm chair of governors at
springfield and i'm very happy to report
that this week the first time
in nearly two years the school is
covered free all our staffering all
actual any children that are off are not
off with coving and i know the school
there have been very very grateful
support they've had when we've had
outbreaks and if you could pass that
back to the team i'd be grateful
okay thank you
any questions at all from anybody
no i don't see any so thank you very
much kirsty um we're now going to uh uh
invite benice to speak to us and bernice
is going to give us some information on
policy change around
surrounding care homes and supported
accommodation living i know she's been
doing a lot of work in that area so
you're very welcome banished and we look
forward to what you've got to say thank
you good morning and thank you chair um
over the past two months um since the
outbr the omicron wave took hold
our public health uh team ipc team
commissioners and outbreak teams have
been working even more closely with our
care homes and our supported
accommodations
we have further
improved our systems where we have
harnessed the power of data
including data capture systems to
identify and monitor outbreaks in these
settings and also to ensure that any
support the care homes and
supported accommodations require is
available
at one point in time in january we had
around 28
settings in an outbreak and at present
we have three
which is
quite quite a change from
january we set up outbreaks meetings
with these settings to provide a safe
place where we can understand
transmission within the settings
provide our recommendations and support
and also to answer any questions or
queries the settings may have
we have been working together as
partners to reduce transmission in these
settings and also to bring the outbreaks
to an end
i would like to state that throughout
these meetings i am i'm incredibly
amazed by the sheer determination and
passion
of staff in these settings who have been
absolutely brilliant and have been um
working incredibly hard throughout the
pandemic to keep our residents safe
the cases in our care home outbreaks
have mostly been staff and not residents
and that demonstrates the excellent use
of ppe in these settings
um where residents have tested positive
they have mostly had headaches or mild
sore throats
and this in itself bears testimony
tested testimony to the success of um
our vaccination program particularly the
booster programs that have kept severe
illness and death at bay
so um there have been a number of
changes that have been uh coming through
um since this week and end of last week
and we have been reviewing these changes
um
so the key changes that i would like to
highlight right now is um the residents
in our care settings have to isolate for
10 days instead of the previous 14 days
um that's also for the staff visiting is
an er
also for the staff um visiting and is an
extremely important part of our care
home life and also for the health and
well-being of the residents so under uh
government guidance there are currently
no restrictions on the number of
visitors a care home residents
can receive
provided they're not classified as being
in an outbreak
visitors should make
arrangements with care homes before
visiting
our settings have ensured that these
visits are done in a safe manners and
robust ipc measures are in place
and back in october we passed visits for
under 16s given the high rates in
traffic so we have now uh unpassed the
visiting restrictions for under 16s
that have been in place since october
thank you
thank you
so if you have any questions thank you
benice are there any questions at all
for benicio
i don't see any thank you very much for
that update um so we now move on to mass
vaccination and invite mark to address
his mark
thank you
so
trafford's
still doing quite well the um the
figures get quite confusing because the
number of people
that we include within the figures seems
to continually change so
um
it's difficult sometimes to see the
progress but
um
at the moment
double vaccinated is considered to be
fully vaccinated rather than
boosted but on the double vaccinated
we have over eight percent of the
eligible population are now
vaccinated the ones who aren't are
mainly in the under 40s
um
and their enthusiasm to turn up for
their second vaccination seems to be
waning um but we're doing the work to
try and encourage those groups to
to
take up the vaccine and particularly the
12 to 15 year olds who only recently
changed to becoming eligible because
their second vaccination has to be three
months after the first um in the boosted
popul boosted population we've got over
85 of those eligible
and again
the eligibility is about time after the
second dose
so
in the ones who
have had the second dose the majority
are getting the booster when it becomes
available
and we have
vaccination sites and pop-up clinics
across the whole of trafford
with plenty of capacity to be able to
pick up
all the remaining jobs that
that are eligible so we've got an
ongoing campaign trying to encourage
people and we have available human
access of all the sites to be able to
facilitate that so we're continuing to
work on that
um
and you know while i can break it down
to a load more detail
um
it all the figures just get confusing um
as far as i'm concerned so i'd be quite
happy to answer any question give you
any specifics you need rather than give
you a long list
by each individual group that we have
the data on
so i'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you uh mark are there any
questions uh helen you've got your hand
up
it's not so much a question it's just a
particular group that we've been working
with um in public health and that's
around the schools program the 12-15 so
you'll be aware that the second dose
program is currently active and
mft are working with colleagues mark's
colleagues from pcns and pharmacy to
deliver the vaccination schools but
sadly what we're hearing is uptake is
really low so um
and we think that's a combination of
young people and children who have
who are quite yet eligible for the
vaccine having been caught up in the
last omicron wave for example i think
it's 28 days isn't it marked between
infection and vaccination but also i
think some issues around um
just some kind of messaging out to
family so i guess what we would ask ped
members is if you're a governor of a
secondary school to maybe raise this as
a discussion uh with your school um in
terms of
uh of working to improve uptake of
vaccination within in within the school
population and the wider community as
well thanks
yes
sorry to follow up on that just just to
give people realistic expectations the
the school service will probably visit
schools once to offer vaccination and
if
anybody is not eligible on that occasion
they're gonna have to
source their vaccination elsewhere
although
um
at least two of our pharmacy sites and
four of our primary care network sites
are now approved to be delivering those
vaccines so there is
a spread of locations across trafford
where children can access that and that
can be they they're through the national
booking services either online or 119 to
be able to access that so if they've
missed it
um through the school unfortunately it's
unlikely there'll be a second visit to
the school
but there are good services available
elsewhere for them to be able to
arrange the vaccination
thanks mark helen have we considered um
for after half term
maybe another uh joint letter
from yourselves um and and ccg maybe to
all heads us
across all secretary schools asking them
to
to get that letter out to parents and
carers
uh to try and drive up the the take of
vaccination in that age group
uh it's definitely something we could
look at i'll have a discussion with mark
about that after this meeting just to
ensure that the offer is um
it's appropriate to but yes absolutely
we'll have a look at that if you could
and also make sure that uh that
it comes back to me and and particularly
the leader of the council um so that we
know exactly where we are with it but i
do think it's something we need to
seriously consider in terms of driving
up that the rate of vaccination in that
age group are there any questions at all
though
for anyone from anyone else
i don't see any so um i'm going to pass
over to danny danny zamit on community
engagement danny
hi thanks chair
and so the team has been supporting all
of the mobile vaccination um sessions
starting later this week
so what we'll be doing there is some
door knocking to promote the sessions
that are going on
and we've also been in contact with the
mainstream schools that we wanted to
support with the 12-15 vaccination
program
and we offered a range of sessions and
the school's agreed to send out
our video to the parents which explains
the 12-15 program
and the consent process
and we're also
i'm going to contact the secondary
school as well and
ask him to promote us
our school vaccination clinics and which
you've kind of just been discussing then
um and we hope it'll encourage those who
weren't able to be vaccinated in school
and to access clinics over half term
and in terms of that program our focus
will now be on the special educational
needs and alternative settings
you'll be visited by the vaccination
teams after half turn
and want to have the conversations with
the schools on the most effective ways
that we can work with the schools and
get the information to families
and we're currently arranging half term
sessions in template
and for children and young people and
we'll link him in with a community group
who are offering um free lunches over
that period
and we'll have a space in their cafe so
that we can speak to the young people
and they can take part in hand hygiene
exercises
which will promote the correct hand
washing techniques
and we've got infection prevention and
control colleagues and who'll support
this where they can
and finally we're also going to be
contacting a number of primary schools
to offer um
delivery sessions in schools
which could be assemblers or classroom
sessions
and find one from what helen said
earlier i want to visit primary schools
particularly in parkinson
and in other areas i've seen high rates
and that's all from me thanks
thanks danny can i just ask on your
travels around the community have you
come up against any anti-vaccine
demonstrations at all or demonstrators
have any issues at all
um not that's been reported back from
from the way that we've been doing
particularly we did some
um sort of on street engagement and just
before christmas in my october november
and nothing nothing sort of two
so it's like too much on that sort of
thing though and i know that and jilla
just over the christmas period in
between christmas and new year she held
and like a q a session just in one of
the
sort of public spaces and i think that
she came up against
a few more sort of anti-vaxx groups that
attended that session but no nothing
more from us
thank you so i just raised it because i
think it is a concern that it does seem
to be
quite some publicity given to them um
through news media and and what we've
seen
recently down in london etc and uh it
does concern me that uh that they're
actually given the air time that they're
given are there any questions at all for
for danny
i don't see any at all thank you well um
our next meeting is going to be on the
23rd of february um
and i hope to look forward to seeing you
there look forward to seeing much lower
rates and also the uh
the information has probably come from
government by then helen on on living
with kovid and and the way forward uh
can i thank you for your attendance and
kind of end again as usual by thanking
all our public health workers uh all the
work that's been done in care homes all
the work through the community
engagement the outbreak management um
we really you know i think we've done a
a job that we can be really proud of in
trafford
and as an exec member i'm told you know
i keep saying this but i've been blown
away by the commitment of our staff in
dealing with this uh this pandemic in
trafford so i'll see you all on the 23rd
of february
thank you very much for your attendance
thank you
thanks bye-bye